Is this the part where the mysterious
guy of the hoodie kicks everybody's ass
why are you mad i am just kidding it's dr
michael morvious i have increased strength
and speed let's see what else i can do okay so i'm
superhuman this year a new marvel legend arrives
you don't look anything like you do on the news
yeah you look downright robust pilates helps
the film version of morbius that we're bringing to
you now he's also a part of a much larger universe
if you've seen the last spider-man no way home
trailer you know the multiverse has officially
opened and there's all kinds of opportunities
for villains to meet up thrive and maybe
even nurture their more sinister intents that's
all i'm gonna say for right now.
Welcome back everyone, this is going to be my new marvel morbius
trailer there's been a lot of talk about the movie
they're dropping a lot of easter eggs talking a
lot about sinister six team up obviously there's a
lot of confusion with what happened during spider
man no way home in that version of the sinister
six from the multiverse as of right now i have not
seen the movie yet but it is coming out soon so
i'll try to explain what their plans are for the
movie there have been a lot of reports about them
changing the movie itself during the edit
after the events of spider man no way home
so i'll explain why they did that and what they
probably wound up changing everybody just hoping
that andrew garfield and toby maguire tom holland
come back at some point if you're brand new to
the channel we're doing a giveaway for disney plus
memberships because marvel's moon knight episodes
are starting next week i'll be doing videos for
all the episodes like all the disney plus series
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and just leave all your favorite easter eggs
from the morbius trailers on the video right
now it kind of seems like the easter eggs for
the movie are way more interesting than
what's actually going on during the movie
just because of all the questions it raises about
how all these different versions of spider-man are
connected between what's going on in the morbius
movie the venom movies and what their plans are
inside the sony universe of marvel characters
but like at the very end of spider-man no way
home you see those cracks in reality where you
see all these versions of multiverse characters
coming to the mcu because of the effects of the
first spell all those characters are spider-man
related characters most of them being multiverse
versions of the sinister six characters like a lot
of these are classic versions of the characters
with animal-based designs like a classic version
of rhino a classic version of craven there's
even a classic version of the spider-man with
the six arms which debuted during the morbius run
and now we're talking about the morbius movie so
all those silhouettes of the spider-man multiverse
characters in the cracks in reality were meant to
be important of things to come like you will
see versions of all these characters coming
in the future of our movies it was meant to be a
wtf moment in the context that they used it like
this is about to get really bad for everybody but
it was also meant to be a teaser for things that
will be happening in the future but we just got
the spider man no way home bonus features deleted
scenes but the writers have since explained
along with the concept artist what their plans
are for the movie were with their plans for toby
mcguire andrew garfield tom hollander with some
of the other characters they wanted to include
we're going to be doing you are amazing thank
you yeah will you say it no i kind of needed to
hear that thank you they broke the multiverse and
they kind of canonized every single thing from
every spider-man franchise including the venom
movies like venom let there be carnage and now
the morbius director has also explained that the
morbius movie and the venom movie are confirmed
to take place inside the same universe on the
same earth if that wasn't clear from the last
morbius trailer where like he literally calls out
venom's catchphrase we are venom no just kidding
we're actually michael morbius i'm the doctor
that turns into the vampire that movie is taking
place in a version of new york city in the venom
universe whereas most of the events of the venom
movie take place on the other side of the country
in san francisco it sounds like a lot of sony's
spin-off movies that they're doing on their own
are on that same planet just to make things
easier for crossovers that they hope to have
as jared leto says during this trailer he
literally calls out the sinister six happening
in future sony driven movies like the only way he
could have been more clear in that teaser was to
say oh yes we are doing a version of sinister six
in the future of our movies there's all kinds of
opportunities for villains to meet up thrive and
maybe even nurture their more sinister intents
now he doesn't explain exactly how they plan
on justifying that like why are they gonna call
it the sinister six who's gonna be on that team
because we just got spider man no way home like i
said and we just saw a version of the sinister six
come together across the multiverse even though
they didn't call it the sinister six and the
ones we did get in the actual movie are basically
almost the entire roster of original sinister six
villains on that first team the only difference is
the green goblin character he wasn't on that
very first roster but you can't do all those
toby mcguire andrew garfield easter eggs and not
bring back a version of willem dafoe green goblin
he definitely understood the assignment for that
movie he had just as much fun as toby mcguire and
andrew garfield did in that movie but at the end
of that movie all three versions of spider-man
basically worked together to fix all those
villains and send them back to their universe with
doctor strange's second spell so arguably going
forward in the timeline all those versions of the
characters have been fixed like they're all good
now so what does that mean for sony's version of
the sinister six that they're putting together it
had to be a completely different roster and that's
basically what their pitch is during the morbius
trailer videos if you go back and you watch like
the first one or two morbius trailer videos i did
a billion years ago it seems like a billion years
ago when we got that first morbius trailer i think
way back during that first or second trailer video
a couple years ago i was actually talking about
them putting the sinister six together with this
version of the vulture the real question was is
how they were going to explain this version of the
vulture showing up in the events of the morbius
movie in a completely different universe while
we just saw what happened with mcu vulture during
spider-man homecoming that's really where all the
questions were like how are they going to explain
this version of the vulture who is he going to be
and how they can explain him showing up being the
exact same version of the character the director
of the morbis movie kind of halfway explained the
vulture scenes during the morbius movie the past
couple days on social media so people were kind of
going crazy but he only halfway explained what's
going on with the vulture so most of what we'll
be talking about after the movie comes out will be
exactly how they justify what it is that they're
doing with their big sinister six spin-off film
but that's basically what's happening like
they're using the morbius movie to set up
a bunch of other movies no big surprise there
they did the same thing with the venom movies
they're including a whole bunch of spider man
easter eggs for all the different versions of
spider-man because they very clearly want to
include a version of spider-man in the future
of their spin-off films the director said that we
would actually learn which version of spider-man
exists inside the morbius and venom universe on
their earth pretty soon because they have so many
tobey mcguire easter eggs in the movie andrew
garfield tom holland even venom easter eggs that
tells me that sony has not completely figured out
how they're gonna handle spider-man inside a lot
of these spin-off movies we joke about the mess
of easter eggs they include in the trailer like
what is going on in this film there are easter
eggs for every single version of spider-man that
has ever existed in creation well the truth is is
that sony hasn't completely figured it out either
i'm sure after the movie comes out there'll
be a lot of jokes about that as well
but because there's been so much andrew garfield
in the news recently he's been doing so many
fantastic movies along with spider man no
way home people have been asking for sony to
legit make amazing spider-man 3 now because they
teased it so much during spider-man no way home
they even just released a promo with amazing
peter number three using the font from amazing
spider-man movies they really want to tease
you with amazing spider-man 3 but a lot of
what they're probably doing with the sinister
six in the movie with all these different easter
eggs for the different versions of spider-man go
back several years to when andrew garfield was
officially their only version of spider-man at
the time before they'd recast with tom holland
and they were doing mcu spider-man stuff so if
you remember the amazing spider-man 2 during
that movie there are a bunch of easter eggs for
a million different things because like all sony
films with spider-man characters they were trying
to set up a billion other films at the same time
most people just remember the sinister six easter
eggs at the end of the film because it was so
overt with those here's a big easter egg for
you too they were actually going to have the
marvel daredevil director the person who did the
daredevil series do a sinister six spin-off film
and this was back during the amazing spider-man 3
era it was basically going to be a version of the
roster that they teased at the end of that movie
and it was going to be completely separate from
the events of amazing spider-man 3. what was going
to happen during amazing spider-man 3 you actually
learned about during the easter eggs earlier in
the film so harry osborne green goblin is looking
in oscorp at all these different files and he
pulls up a whole bunch of easter eggs here like
zoom in enhance you can see them all here there
were easter eggs for a version of venom showing
up in his universe a version of blade a version
of morbius felicity jones in this movie was
playing a version of black cat that would become
black cat in the sequels a lot of those easter
eggs like an andrew garfield symbiote saga
they would address an amazing spider-man 3
while at the same time they were doing a spin-off
film with a legit version of the sinister six
so what's happened in present day is that
a lot of the same producers are working on
the franchise in these new sony spin-off films
in present day they want to circle back around
and do the exact same thing with all their
versions of the characters that they control
they want to do that spin-off sinister six film
and because they've had a couple venom movies
now they have the morbius movie they're
trying to use those movies to set that up
whatever their deal with marvel is with sharing
the characters apparently that extends to a lot
of the spin-off characters too like mcu vulture
you probably heard about a couple of the other
spin-off films that they're shooting right now
like they're shooting a craven movie with aaron
taylor johnson who is mcu quicksilver i can't wait
for the memes when that movie comes out next year
their new spin-off version the sinister six that
the morbius movie is supposedly setting up is
going to involve that character and a lot of the
other brand new characters that they introduce
they've already talked about having another mcu
crossover with the morbius character like blade is
a vampire hunter there's this big marvel midnight
suns team up that they have slowly assembling
through the new version the blade movie like you
have kit harington's black knight character black
knight vampire hunter with the ebony blade you
have a version of moon knight that's going to
debut next week you have a version of ghost rider
though eventually introduced you have a version
of werewolf by night so if they're going to be
hunting a lot of supernatural creatures inside
the mcu it makes sense that they would try to
find a way to include more beast's character who's
built for that kind of stuff my full post credit
scene will probably post next friday after the
movie officially releases and then i'll do like a
full breakdown video explaining all the different
easter eggs and how everything works together
click here for my brand new marvel moon knight
episode 1 trailer video in easter eggs and click
here for that really cool marvel nova announcement
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!